Part B why have I asked you to do Part B
well even though you're like I'm done
I've just convinced it on Desmos right
there's a really important reason why I
hope you'll see the point in us saying
can we confirm the result again not just
by using technology but by solving the
original equations that we had the
vector equations okay so let's do this
all together this is puppy
let's write it here
and I'm going to begin just by writing
the two equations that I'm solving right
so here's my straight line we already
said before it's five two plus Lambda
negative 2 3 and then I also have the
circle which we haven't written that as
Vector form I don't think in component
form anyway this is what I've got if I
think about the circle okay so I'm going
to ball these two together now when
solving simultaneously I'm doing just
the same thing as I did with the
Cartesian equation I'm substituting one
thing into the other but it's a bit
weird because you know this is the
arbitrary Vector on one side and this is
the arbitrary Vector on the other right
the variable I should say so therefore
weirdly I'm going to substitute R into V
that's what solving simultaneously looks
like in this context okay so let's let's
just write that out so I've got the um
the magnitude there and just to make it
very obvious what I'm doing here here's
the 5 2 plus lamb Lambda negative 2 3
that I get from the straight line and
then I've got take away one eight that
comes from the circle and that's the
square root of 13.
okay
now it looks weird but on the left hand
side there what you've really got is
just it's just Vector arithmetic like
you don't even need to think about what
the geometry of this is just think about
the numbers right if you look across the
top you've got all three of the X
components there five minus two Lambda
and then minus one and you've also got
the Y components so there's no reason
why I can't just ball them all up
together into one thing uh just think
about the consonants what's five take
away one that's four
and then I've got a minus two Lambda
there does that make sense and then
looking at the Y component uh two take
away eight that's going to be oops sorry
about that negative six and then I'm
adding three Lambda and that's
everything all together on the left hand
side
okay help me out what do we do at this
point
um
okay yes we absolutely can factorize
um and I can because it's a it's a
um a scalar multiple um on the top and
the bottom it's going to end up being
though a fraction like you'll you'll
because we don't have a matching
um a matching uh scalar to take out of
the X component and the Y component
um yeah you can take it you know a
fraction and I think that would be it
would make this Vector nicer but then
you'd end up with a fraction right so
I'm actually going to not do that it
does make my numbers a bit bigger but
it's it's still fine what can we do with
this to start to solve for Lambda
because that's the unknown here
yeah very good so um this is a magnitude
right so I can just work that out using
Pythagoras right um and then I might as
well Square all of that so that I don't
have square roots flying around because
there's just a square on the left Square
to the right so what I end up with is
here's the uh x squared as it were here
is the Y squared
and then here is the
um distance squared right and so I know
this is a bit gross but you can you see
this is kind of uh equivalent to us
trying to solve the like expand out the
um equation of the circle right so
therefore here
um I mean there's lots of different
things I could do why don't we just
expand it out because we haven't done
the expansion today
I'm going to pull on this trick that
I've just seen me do before which is
that I'm going to write these as um two
separate lines just so that I can um
collect like terms a little more easily
so then I've got 36
take away 36 Lambda
plus nine Lambda squared
does that look okay to you guys
yep so what I've got here 15 sorry 16
plus 36 that's 52 I get that again and
then I get 13 Lambda squared and then
again when I said it was equivalent I
wasn't kidding right like because all
the numbers are the same that's why
you're getting the same kind of oh look
I've got um things that are multiples of
13 right let's just tidy this up for a
second before I do the division let's
have our Lambda squared out the front 52
Lambda and I've actually got constants
on both sides right so I might as also
track 13 from both sides that gives me
plus 39.
okay I'll divide through now and that
gives me a nice neat quadratic in Lambda
so can someone tell me the factorization
[Music]
fantastic so
that of course gives us our two
solutions Lambda equals one or three and
remember what Lambda is is telling me
like how far along to go on the line
right so if you have a think about
um doing the supposition back into our
original equation
um I'm actually going to let you
continue doing this but I'll just do it
for one just so you can see and when we
go into the X components uh where's the
equation gone it's here
I'll just grab it so that it's within
View
here it is
okay so my X is going to be five take
away two which is three
and then my Y is going to be what's that
uh two plus three right
which is five this is the same three
comma five point that we got before and
I'll leave it for you to do the working
to confirm that you get the negative one
comma 11 out of this okay
now just as a final point so hooray we
confirmed it right actually sorry I take
it back two final points my first
question to you is which did you prefer
did you prefer method a or did you
prefer method B
you liked a that's that's interesting to
me that you liked a because I'm just
I've got I've got method B here on
screen this is how long it took I just
want you to compare it with method a
it's it's it's about 50 more lines
um and I even knew the algebra right now
maybe it's the fact that it leans on
like Cartesian stuff which you know very
well so you get out of the vectors and
then you're like great I'll use all the
stuff I already know right it turns into
like a year 11 question right it's your
life hooray okay
um however just objectively it is less
working to do it by Vector arithmetic if
you're comfortable so this is a little
bit like you know there are questions
where you can do them in radians or
degrees but when radians are weird in
your brain you're like I'm just gonna
convert it in degrees in my brain and
then off I go right but if you can think
about it in radians it's better
um the other thing I wanted to point out
just as a secondary thing is uh the
Lambda equals one and Lambda equals
three just think about what that means
let's go back to Desmos for a minute
right
what was the um what's it called what's
the um position Vector that we use to
get this line do you remember what it
was
um five comma two so it's actually down
here
five comma two and then we said that the
direction Vector that was supplied was
um was it
two
negative two three right so what is that
that is um go two units to the left
sorry which way is left for you guys
that way and then three units up right
so think about what's that do what
that's doing it goes two units to the
left and then three units up can you see
this Lambda equals one means do that
direction vector and do it once you see
that that's what that's what produces
this right and then when you get the
other value of Lambda which is Lambda
equals three what does that correspond
to
yeah do it do it three times instead of
once so you can see there's the second
time you do it and then there's the
third time and that's what gets you to
the other side of the circle so we
actually have a diameter here
um and that's that's actually how I
chose it because I knew the numbers
would be nice and easy for me and that's
why I knew I had faith that it would
simplify even though you had weird
fractions and 13s and stuff like that
okay so I just think it's very helpful
that not only do you just get numbers
out you're like Lambda equals one Landry
because three good for you
um I want you to think geometrically in
terms of what that's doing which is
moving you along the line and um you
know just like when we talked about the
other place you see a parameter which is
the unit circle what is changing Theta
doing and the answer is it's moving you
around the circle it's it's sort of um
shifting from from place to place in a
continuous way that's what that's what
parameters do